[Music]
Federation so I give my you grab be
strong so always remember that the
energy I'm talking about is not the
physical power it's the internal power
keep
tur I'm moving Toe to Toe as I'm turning
my body it's not a movement
I move around my
Center I'm
180 for instance if I'm in this position
here push so this shouldn't
happen if he's pushing he's pushing so I
have a stable position in uh
so if he's
pulling this should not
happen if he's pulling stop if he's
pushing this should not happen I have to
have a stable
position now my body is strong and ready
to move on has to be hey bring it out
so so this is no energy coming
out
hey that is bringing the energy out
through
breathing through your fingers and don't
stop
anyway the next level still tight hand I
respond or I move exactly as he grabs
this
we call it a more flexible flexible
level time
like like the wind in the
grass and the third form
flowing like this we call it flowing or
re
T the water so you have some references
into to the
nation therefore we should be very
careful in how we are moving our bodies
that might differ differ between
different
styles we make it flowing
form uh
watch now I'm stepping into the same
position as I was in before here
grabbing same hand as was a stronger
hand before is still the stronger hand
but I have to grab myself this
way
move turn use both hands because that is
stronger and it's easier to Center the
movement
that kind of motion as well but it's
important
that stepping
in my point
is never
attack with the intention to take the
uky we blend
it because
can immediately get up and attack me
again and we
moved this way
so three ways moving we were doing the
forms we were doing the form we were
doing moving this Chang to the other H
so there are
many details
involve
one is this
mov as he grabs
because this is a strong
movement don't Mo so I just move my sens
just a little bit and I can easily bring
him
off if I'm trying to take a step here I
will get Stu so therefore like this and
in the attack
form then
I for
C be the
last slly
back down
through free